[Music]
so I was born with a certain name
that's only only my parents used
basically that's my legal name and then
my dad he's an artist he's always liked
naming people he gives people names it's
like a blessing and he gifted me a name
and then in school I wanted an American
name so I went by Alice and that's why I
have essentially three names
my name is nari Seoul I'm a pianist
composer and I like making videos
writing music and just making stuff
about music surrounding music anything
related to music
[Music]
really loading Manhattan now and this is
where I practice pretty often is where I
can practice on an acoustic ground down
okay my first video was June 2nd 2017
and it was just a compilation of what I
was practicing along with shots is my
dog stuff outside I uploaded because I
was bored
and I'm a millennial and you do stuff
like that I don't know why do people
watch I can't speak for my viewers but
maybe part of what's interesting is that
someone from the classical music world
is doing other genres because as a
classical musician generally speaking of
course there are tons of Accession
exceptions but generally speaking
classical musicians are quite insular in
terms of what they listen to what music
they expose themselves to what music
that they play YouTube has changed my
life completely
oh that's a great question what I'd
rather listen to music or play music
I think listen I'm not I'm obviously
really attached to the piano but I like
music more than I do the piano and I
like writing more than I do playing a
lot of times when I'm writing I want to
there's a certain sound that I want to
hear that maybe I'll first try to find
on Spotify or get to
somewhere else and then other times I
just write stuff that comforts me a lot
of stuff that we go through emotionally
in our daily lives is very complicated
so you can even learn we're feeling
happy or
sad it's very complicated
so to create something that matches that
I think
helpful because you can create something
that is you know light and warm but with
an undertone of
being unsettling but also hopeful but
kind of pessimistic but happy you know
it's complicated so it's just finding a
medium that compliments how you're
feeling so when I'm here I am basically
in this room 24/7 I just go to the
bathroom and I don't spend any time
outside you don't use a kitchen at all
so when I'm here I'm here this is my
keyboard to see p88 I really like it
this is my computer that I do everything
on oops this is my camera this is my
favorite small keyboard yeah no it's not
plugged in I did a lot of videos on this
one
and I still really like it it's cute
that's the most important thing that's
cute
want to show the guitar I bought a
little guitar it's a a kid guitar
because I want to learn guitar it's my
favorite instrument actually
[Music]
and I remember my first teacher didn't
really teach me anything the only thing
I can remember about her was that she
had this giant mole on the back of her
neck so when she was teaching me so
you'd be standing right and she's
demonstrating I was so bored that I just
looked at her mole my parents were not
typical stage parents so what they're
called yeah I didn't practice so much
until I went to high school so when I
first started I would practice maybe 45
minutes a day not even an hour for the
longest time
the simplest I could put it is that I'm
not the most talented but I make up for
it
I think what I want to accomplish is
rather simple
I just want to spread enthusiasm about
music for music the love for music I
think there's always room for that where
this will all lead I have no idea I just
I just know that I want to keep refining
my skills and get to a place where I'm
writing music that I am that I want to
hear and that I think can you know be a
nice addition to the music that's out
there
I think it's an obsession I just like it
I feel very comfortable with music I
feel happy I know it's cliche but I feel
happy it's kind of music it's kind of
like eating but you don't need food you
don't necessarily need food to survive
you can be plugged into IV or what does
it call whatever the little something
that provides nutrition for you so if I
didn't have music I think another thing
like music will provide what music
provides for me to live does that make
sense
[Music]